- My content is pretty happy
and I'm a happy dude and--
- Do you get good engagement?
- What's that?
(group laughter)
Do you know what's funny?
- I'm just interested,
do you get--
- Negativity is a
lot easier to sell.
- Yeah.
- That's why it's working.
What I do for
living is much harder.
I'm trying to win on positivity
which is the hardest sell.
You're either on
offense or you're not.
- [Man] Yeah.
- To me, dwelling is
super not interesting.
It's got zero value.
You need to be thoughtful,
you need to understand,
you need to not have too
much ego to lack of humility
that why did we get
here but dwelling?
I'm not interested in dwelling
of what just happened
in our countries.
I'm interested in
being on the offense to
A, start closing the
gap back to the social.
I care about the social impacts.
I sent an email to the entire
company today of an emoji heart.
That was it.
Or I think I wrote something
like, "I love you," or something
but the emails that
I got back was so insane.
Just like people
really needed it.
It takes so little to do,
it's so easy to say,
"Hey," or wink at somebody
or just smile but it's not
because you actually have to
believe it and people
don't actually believe it.
(light music)